Es ist Zeit, auf den europäischen Fußball der Männer zu blicken. Und das heißt, heute in der Ligatour sprechen wir über La Liga, die Serie A, die Premier League und die Eredivisie mit Daniel Zander, Mario Rieker, Jogi Hebel, Nies Kern. Jetzt geht's los!
Und nun im Programm der Rasenfunk.
So und herzlich willkommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Schönen Gruß in meine Runde. Wir sparen uns jetzt den Lehrer-Call. Ich versuche, ihn wegzulassen. Schön, dass ihr alle da seid. Ihr müsst nicht reagieren. Wir gehen gleich rein in die Sendung. Wir wollen es so kompakt halten, wie möglich. Und ich würde sagen, Yogi, dass wir in der Premier League beginnen. Denn die Entlassung von Eric ten Hag bei Manchester United, finally. Ich hätte schon gedacht, dass wir letztes Jahr oder vorletztes Jahr das mal in der Ligatur besprechen. Jetzt ist es dann doch passiert. Was hat denn das fast zum Überlaufen gebracht?
Ja, mit Sicherheit das Spiel am Wochenende. Das 1 zu 2 gegen West Ham. West Ham ist eine Mannschaft, die momentan gar nichts auf die Kette kriegt, die dann aber trotzdem 2 zu 1 gegen United gewinnt. Dazu natürlich dann auch diese Ergebnisse davor. Gegen Fenerbahce zum Beispiel nur 1 zu 1 in der europäischen unterwegs. Da haben sie ja drei Spiele, drei unentschieden. Das ist einfach insgesamt nicht gut genug, muss man ganz klar sagen. Dann waren sie, glaube ich, 14. der Premier League. Ich schaue gleich mal nach parallel. Das ist einfach zu wenig für Manchester United und für die Ansprüche und auch für die Ausgaben. Das ist ja auch klar, ich bin auch 14. Das ist dann einfach nicht gut genug. Und dann war es irgendwann mal klar, dass es passieren würde. Es gab schon mal nach dem ersten Villaspiel eine Sitzung. Da kam sogar ein Glacier aus Amerika angeflogen und alle anderen zusammen haben sich in London getroffen, um mal zu besprechen, wie geht es weiter. Da war nicht so klar, ob es da um 10.8 geht oder nicht. Es ging dann wohl doch um ihn. Nur da haben sie noch gesagt, naja, 0-0 gegen Eston Villa ist doch jetzt wieder okay. Gegen so ein gutes Team, Unai Emery und so weiter. Wir geben dem jetzt noch mal eine Chance. Und dann, gut, ein Monat später war es dann vorbei. Wie du es selbst schon gesagt hast, das kam jetzt nicht so überraschend. Ich habe mit Benny Grund vor einem Jahr schon darüber gesprochen, ob er den Winter noch überleben wird. Das ist halt so. Es war zu erwarten.
Und deswegen ist es ja auch so ein bisschen fast schon ironisch, dass es dann so von einzelnen Spielergebnissen noch abhing. Ich weiß, dass es jetzt eine große Frage für wenig Zeit ist. Aber woran ist denn Erik Ten Haag letztlich jetzt dann bei United gescheitert? Er hatte ja tatsächlich viel Zeit. Am 1. Juli 2022 hat er sein Amt angetreten. Also er hat jetzt über zwei Jahre bekommen.
Also grundsätzlich, man hat ja im Sommer, das habt ihr wahrscheinlich auch mitbekommen, mit Thomas Tuche schon gesprochen. Hätte der jetzt irgendwie gesagt, ich mach das, hätte der irgendwie so einen Eindruck hinterlassen, dass man gesagt hätte, man muss den haben, dann hätte man es da wahrscheinlich schon gemacht. Das Ding war halt, aber er hat danach dann das FA Cup-Finale noch gewonnen. Und dann haben natürlich alle gesagt, naja gut, FA Cup-Finale gewinnen, da kannst du den nicht rausschmeißen. Das kommt in einer Hand auch dazu. Ihr wisst ja auch alle, wie es ist. Es kommt ein neues Regime, in Anführungszeichen. Und dann heißt es halt sofort, dann wollen wir auch unsere eigenen Leute haben. Das kann man sogar irgendwo nachvollziehen. Grundet sich, woran hat es gelegen? Also spielerisch, fand ich es ehrlich gesagt nie deutlich besser als unter Ole Gunnar Soscha zum Beispiel. Weil es oft, das Spiel ist ja darauf ausgelegt, ins Tempo zu kommen. Also du versuchst schnell zu überbrücken. Du versuchst schnell den Ball rauszugeben auf zum Beispiel Rashford, damit der gehen kann. Dann hast du aber oftmals das Problem, dass du noch einen weiten Weg bis zum Tor hast, weil du so tief verteidigst, dass du das eine alleine erst mal 60 Meter überbrücken musst, das aber nicht hinbekommt, Ball ist weg, Tempo ist raus. Oder du spielst halt dann so, wenn du das Tempo nicht hinbekommst, spielst du so lange um den Strafraum rum, dass du dann wieder auf Einzelaktionen angewiesen bist. Nach hinten ist das Problem, wenn du dann vorne dieses Handballspielchen betreibst, dann bist du halt im Mittelfeld oftmals so offen gewesen, bei einem Ballgewinn sofort durchgelaufen. Daraufhin hatten die Mannschaften oft kein Mittelfeld vor sich und konnten einfach durchbrücken, durchausbüxen. Ich habe das zuletzt so oft gesehen und das war einfach nicht mehr praktikabel. Dazu Transfers. Der hat sehr, sehr viel Geld ausgegeben. Ich glaube, 600 Millionen oder so, die er ausgegeben hat. Er hat die Mannschaft einfach insgesamt nicht besser gemacht. Man kann sich die einzelnen Transfers anschauen. Der Königstransfer, Leni Juro, verletzt. Okay, kann er nichts dafür, dass der sich verletzt. Der ist aber 18. Er kann die Abwehr nicht leiten von Manchester United. Das geht ja nicht. Du hast mit der Ligt jemanden geholt, den du ja eigentlich schon so ähnlich im Kader hast. Nämlich mit McGuire hast du auch einen großen, kantigen Defense-First-Verteidiger. Das heißt, du bist nicht deutlich besser geworden. Du holst mit circa zehn Stürmer. Ja, jetzt hast du zwei, aber du hast zwei, die nicht funktionieren und viel Geld gekostet haben und so weiter und so fort. Du hast die sechs jetzt endlich mal besetzt mit Ugarte. Der wiederum braucht aber auch noch Zeit. Und er ist dann im Endeffekt jemand, der schon etwas bringen kann, der gut ist in allem dem, was er macht. Aber er ist halt trotzdem ein, ja, schon auch ein fehlerbehafteter Spieler, weil er halt so über aggressiv ist. Und so hast du halt nur Probleme an allen Orten, die du einfach nicht hinbekommst. Und dann natürlich auch die ganzen Themen abseits des Felles. Rashford ist plötzlich in Irland unterwegs und geht da einheben. Du hast die Geschichte mit Ronaldo gehabt, du hast die Geschichte mit Jadon Sancho gehabt. Das alles irgendwo, jetzt dann irgendwo gebündelt mit keinen Ergebnissen. Und, und das ist dann, glaube ich, der Punkt, der irgendwann mal gereicht hat, katastrophalen Pressekonferenzen, also bei denen er einfach irgendwann nur noch Quatsche erzählt hat, wie zum Beispiel, ich weiß nicht, das werdet ihr ja auch gehört haben, diese Pressekonferenz dann, wo er nach dem Spiel, als er gesagt hat, gegen Fenerbahce, also vor dem Spiel gegen Fenerbahce, als er gesagt hat, ich bin so ein Typ wie Jose Mourinho, ich gewinne überall. Und das ist ja totaler Quatsch, weil Jose Mourinho ist ein Top-10-Trainer aller Zeiten. Tenar ist nicht mal Top-10 Premier League jetzt. Und solche Sätze halt rauszuhauen, da brauchst du dich halt einfach nicht wundern, dass Leute das irgendwie kritisch sehen. Auch so Sachen wie, sagt der ja wirklich, jede Woche hat er das wiederholt, dass man ihn doch erst dann einschätzen soll nach der Saison, weil noch ist ja nichts vorbei. Das Problem ist halt aber, dass sie halt Woche für Woche Punkte liegen lassen und jetzt Rang 14 sind. Also ihr alle wisst, wenn es ja mal darum ging, United soll Titel gewinnen, was er ja gesagt hat. Mit Rang 14 jetzt, das kannst du jetzt schon vergessen. Und das ist ja irgendwann dann wirklich auch so ein Meme geworden in den englischen Medien, dass alle sagen, also komm, was redet der da wieder? Es ist halt immer das Gleiche und es passiert aber nichts.
Und wird jetzt dann Ruben Amorim von Sporting United retten?
Also da bin ich auch sehr gespannt. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie es in Englisch ist. Nur man sagt ja immer allein schon als Spieler, dass du eine Zeit brauchst, dich einzugewöhnen in der Premier League, ob du jetzt als Trainer das sofort hinbekommst. Und ja, der ist damals sensationell Meister geworden in den Jahren. Danach gab es schon aber auch Probleme. Also ich bin sehr gespannt, ob das passt. Ich mag das Projekt, in Anführungszeichen, weil jetzt einfach den nächsten Namen zu holen und den zu verbrennen, finde ich Quatsch. Jetzt mal jemanden zu holen. Die Frage ist halt wiederum, hat man bei Manchester United Zeit? Kann man was aufbauen? Ist das überhaupt möglich? Und ist es überhaupt möglich in dieser Umgebung?
Das ist die Frage, die ich mir stelle.
Aber was würdest du denn sagen steckt in diesem Kader drin? Wenn du dir den Kader anschaust und den Rest der Premier League, du hast ja beides sehr gut im Blick. Wo müsste United eigentlich liegen? Also was ist quasi das Potenzial, das ein Trainer heben könnte?
Also ich denke, dass du Top 6 schon sein kannst, aber Chelsea ist die jüngste Mannschaft der Liga. Die haben weit mehr Potenzial. Mareska kriegt es momentan hin, dass sie sie funktionabel zu bekommen. Also vor Brighton sollte man schon stehen, so auf Rang 6. Das wäre schon machbar, wenn du es hinbekommst. Nur er hat es aus dieser Mannschaft nie irgendwie rausholen können. Das ist das ganze Potenzial. Das ist das große Problem. Weil das System ist schon sehr, sehr aufwendig. Ich habe es ja gerade gesagt, es geht schnell rauf und runter, wenn du Pech hast. Und dafür brauchst du halt Spieler, die eine Menge hinbekommen, die eigentlich Allrounder sind. Du brauchst überall den perfekten Allrounder. Und das kriegst du halt so nicht hin. Deswegen, ich finde, der Kader ist nicht so gut, wie viele ihn machen. Die Namen, ja, zusammengestellt ist er nicht gut.
Wir werden sicherlich noch öfter über United sprechen. Das habe ich so im Gefühl. Denn das ist natürlich die Story aus der Premier League. Dann wollen wir mal nach Italien blicken. Mario, es wird höchste Zeit, dass wir mal über Napoli sprechen. Die sind immer wieder schon mitgelaufen hier in der Ligatur. Letztlich ist es ja eine Dominanz mit Ansage. Also wenn man weiß, dass man Zeit hat für Training bei diesem Trainer, dann wundert einem eine Bilanz von 18 zu 5 Toren, 8 Siegen einem Unentschieden und einer Niederlage nicht. Aber jetzt müssen wir trotzdem mal thematisieren, was Napoli eigentlich gemacht hat, um dorthin zu kommen.
Ja, es war ganz lustig. Ich musste gerade schon an Conte denken bei dem Trainer-Vergleich. Der hat jetzt auch noch mal gesagt– ich habe aus Tottenheim das Beste rausgeholt. Und das ist ja auch einer, der vor Selbstvertrauen strotzt. Aber er beweist es dann auch meistens. Er ist der Klassische. Ich komme her und mache die Spieler nicht besser, aber ich mache sie wieder zu dem, was sie können, weil ich ihnen sowas von– pardon– in den Arsch trete. Und Napoli, wir erinnern uns alle, Meister vorletzte Saison, dann jetzt in der vergangenen Spielzeit ein kompletter Downfall. Also da waren so viele Spieler so schlecht. Und jetzt haben sie tatsächlich auch noch vermeintlich ihren Top-Stürmer abgegeben. Über den redet gar keiner mehr, weil Lukaku, über den auch die meiste Zeit jetzt zuletzt negativ geredet wurde, der unter Conte auch wieder funktioniert. Und ansonsten hast du da schon ganz wesentliche Punkte, glaube ich, angesprochen. Sie sind komplett raus aus irgendeiner Dreifachbelastung. Also ja klar, Pokal spielt man noch ein bisschen so nebenher mit. Und ansonsten wird trainiert, gepumpt und dann zwischenzeitlich auch einfach mal dreckig 1 zu 0 gewonnen. Und jetzt haben sie halt unter der Woche das Auswärtsspiel bei Milan gewonnen mit 2 zu 0, was so einen Auftakt in die Wochen der Wahrheit. Aber sie haben jetzt dann am Wochenende kommen, also sie haben jetzt davor gegen Teams auch aus einem unteren Tabellensegment gespielt, wo sie sich sehr schwer getan haben. Aber dann fahren sie nach Mailand und gewinnen ohne großen Aufhebens mit 2 zu 0. Quarantz-Kelje trifft, Lukaku trifft und bauen die Tabellenführung auf, dass es schon bemerkenswert ist. Also es ist teilweise zynisch, wie er spielen lässt, aber auch immer genau so viel, wie es braucht, wird reingelegt. Ich bin sehr gespannt jetzt eben auf das, was kommt. Jetzt kommt Atalanta, Inter, also so ein bisschen die größeren Gradmesser. Aber sie haben auch schon bei Juve 0-0 gespielt. Das war ein klassisches Spitzenspiel, wie es in Italien vielleicht aus den 90er-Jahren man sich hätte denken können. Aber sie haben dann eine sehr gute Mischung aus kontrollierter Offensive und dem Selbstverständnis, dass er Conte ihnen zurückgegeben hat, dass sie einfach jederzeit in der Lage sind, kein Tor reinzulassen und zu gewinnen. So würde ich sagen, das sind die Basics.
Aber wie blickst du denn jetzt dann auf die Wochen der Wahrheit, wie du sie genannt hast? Also jetzt Atalanta zu Hause, Inter auswärts und Rom zu Hause, also die AS Roma zu Hause. Glaubst du, das ist genau der Fußball, der auch erfolgsversprechend ist, den man spielt? Weil man könnte jetzt ja auch über einen 1-0 in Empoli oder Lecce, da könnten wir ja auch sehr einfach diskutieren, ob das wirklich so doll ist jenseits vom Ergebnis.
Ja, also tatsächlich in Fan-Greisen wurde da auch schon viel kritisiert. Das ist halt auch irgendwie ein sehr emotionales Konklumerat da rund um die SSC, ehrlicherweise. Wobei ich mir auch gedacht habe, also was wollt ihr denn jetzt? Ihr seid ja Tabellenführer, nachdem ihr letztes Jahr irgendwie Zehntel geworden seid und jetzt seid ihr schon wieder nur am Meckern. Aber ja…
Legt sich erstmal in die Eistonne, oder was?
Ja, genau. Es gibt Spielphasen unter Conte, die schon einem so ein bisschen die Frage aufwerfen, müsste da nicht eigentlich mehr gehen. Aber, das ist natürlich auch eine Phrase, aber keiner fragt doch im Mai nächsten Jahres, wie Mitte Oktober das Spiel gegen Letsche gewonnen wurde. So, also aus der Perspektive gesehen. Und er ist halt auch einer, der dann in den Partien kaum rotiert. Er hat dann mal vielleicht Quas Keilja draußen gelassen und David Neves einen Neuzugang spielen lassen. Aber, und Gonke hat mal gespielt. Aber ansonsten spielen meistens die acht, neun Stammspieler, die sich dann in solchen Wochen auf dem Platz auch irgendwie ihre Belastungssteuerung nehmen und dann vielleicht damit mit nur der halben Energie rangehen und Konter Fußball ist schon, damit es richtig gut aussieht, braucht es schon viel Energie. Also würde ich das nicht zu hoch hängen. Jetzt ist es in der Phase der Saison, finde ich, sehen halt auch andere Teams inter noch nicht so überzeugend aus, wie ich sie eingeschätzt hätte, sowohl in der Champions League als auch in der Liga. Atalanta ist immer irgendwie so ein Spiel 6-0 gewinnen und dann spielen die in der Champions League 0-0 gegen Celtic, wo man auch denkt, wo kommt das jetzt her? Also auch die sind auf der Suche, ihren Rhythmus zu finden in diesen englischen Wochen. Und da würde ich sozusagen jetzt irgendwie das positive Ding bei Conte anlegen wollen, dass er da zum richtigen Zeitpunkt in der Saison eher auf den langfristigen Fortschritt und die Entwicklung wertlegt, als darauf jetzt irgendwelche Leute überzeugen zu müssen, dass man halt gegen Lecce irgendwie 3-0 gewinnt und dann Hurra-Fußball spielt. Weil er ist halt gekommen, um Meister zu werden. Das ist sein Ding.
Er macht genau das, was wir letztlich auch hier schon vor der Saison besprochen haben im letzten Jahr, schon als es dann quasi ging, kommt, konnte. Also es deckt die Erwartung aber im positiven Sinne. Gibt es denn aber bei den Spielern, wenn du auf den Kader guckst, gibt es da Leute, die dich positiv oder vielleicht auch negativ überraschen?
Also wen ich super finde, der auch gleich sich in die Herzen der Napoli-Fans gespielt hat, ist Scott McTominay. Da hätten wir wieder die. Das ist auch einer, den, ich weiß nicht, ob er den besser gemacht hat, aber er hat es halt dazu, er hat halt dafür gesorgt, dass der angezündet ist. Und ich meine, Yogi wird ihn auch ganz gut kennen. Der bringt eine unheimliche Dynamik mit. Den kannst du hinten vom Strafraum aufräumen lassen. Der kann Box-to-Box spielen. Der kann irgendwie noch den Übertritt ins Schlusstrittel mit initiieren. Strahlt selber Torgefahr aus. Ja, ist an Deck 99 Prozent des Platzes ab, so gefühlt. Ja, und guter Transitionspieler auf jeden Fall für das Contespiel. Der andere Neuzugang aus England, wenn wir kurz da auf der Insel bleiben, Billy Gilmour, tut sich ein bisschen schwer, spielt aber gegen Milan auch unauffällig gut. Bei ihm muss man halt sagen, der hat jetzt gerade die Aufgabe, einen Stanislav Lobotka zu vertreten, der angeschlagen ist. Und wer jetzt irgendwie die letzten Jahre hier auch mal öfter mal reingehört hat, hat den Namen vielleicht auch schon positiv bemerkt.
Kann man auch einfach die letzte Europa-Ausgabe der Ligatour reinhören. Da war Ansan Hiro.
Ja, guck, siehst du, und der fehlt jetzt halt gerade. Ansonsten, bei wem ich so dieses ganz Krasse, er ist wieder bei alter Stärke, ist für mich Franck Anguisin. Das ist so ein Spieler, der kommt so krass über Zweikämpfe und Einstellung und diese körperliche Dynamik. Und das ist so einer, wenn der nur halb, auf halbem Leistungsniveau spielt, finde ich, wirkt das immer, als wäre er der schlechteste Spiel auf dem Platz. Das ist auch, glaube ich, so ein großen Rucksack, den er mit sich rumtragen muss. Also, das ist, glaube ich, der erste, auf den man einschlägt. Und der war dann in der letzten Saison, als viele, viele schlecht waren, da hat man wirklich gedacht, was ist denn mit ihm los? Und der hat wieder dieses Ding, dass er jeden Zweikampf führt, als wäre es sein letzter. Das ist alles, wo ich mir denke, der hat einen kleinen Antonio auf der Schulter sitzen, der ihn die ganze Zeit anschreit. Und das macht wieder Spaß, ihm zuzugucken. Hinten in der Defensive ist Bonjong nun ein Riesen-Upgrade. Der kam aus Torino. Und das war letzte Saison ein bisschen so das Problem. Dann hat man vielleicht fast vergessen, man hat Kim an die Bayern abgegeben, der davor in der Meistersaison der Verteidiger der Serie A schlecht hin war. Und dann war der weg und man hat das versucht, so mit ihren sonst eigentlich Rotationsspielern wie Juan Jesus aufzufüllen, was einfach nicht funktioniert, weil der ist ein guter IV, mal für zweite Runde Coppa Italia, aber bestimmt nicht halt für die Startelf. Und das hat dann auch dafür gesorgt, dass andere Leute daneben in der Innenverteidigung wie Rachmani gewackelt haben. Jetzt kommt mit Bonciono einer, der letzte Saison bei Torino super stark war. Und er gibt dem Ganzen wieder so eine Sicherheit, dass die um ihn herum auch wieder besser werden. Also sozusagen sowohl der Trainer als auch die Spieler untereinander machen sich alle gegenseitig wieder besser. Und das ist vielleicht– Napoli ist wieder ein Kollektiv.
Also Sonntag, 12.30 Uhr. Da könnt ihr mal schön zum Mittagessen euch das Topspiel Napoli gegen Atalanta anschauen. Glückwunsch nochmal an die Spieltagsplanung von dieser Stelle hier. Aber es wird gerannt und gekämpft werden. Tonschancen verspreche ich euch jetzt lieber nicht, man weiß es nicht. Also bei allem, wo Atalanta seine Füße mit drin hat, kann es in jede Richtung ausschlagen. Du hast es ja schon gesagt. Aber das kann man sich definitiv angucken. Und dann ist aber die Frage, Nils, was kann man sich denn bei Real Madrid gerade so angucken?
Ja, da gab es zuletzt vielleicht ein paar klassische Sachen von Real Madrid, wenn man das so nennen will.
Ich muss dich ganz kurz unterbrechen. Ich muss kurz vorher klären. Ich habe gerade einen Anruf bekommen. Wie negativ wirst du jetzt sprechen? Weil ansonsten kommen die 50 Delegierten von Real, die kommen dann doch nicht hier zu mir ins Büro, weil sie beleidigt sind.
Ich werde jetzt zumindest nicht loben, dass man vielleicht am Montag irgendwo plötzlich bessere Dinge zu tun hatte. Okay, dann lasse ich die Tür lieber zu.
Wenn es klingelt, mache ich nicht auf.
Gut, dann lasse ich die Tür lieber zu, weil der Shitstorm kommt dann danach vielleicht. Mal gucken. Klassisch ist ja erstmal, dass man natürlich ein Klassiko zu Hause, dass man sich da mal einen Debakel einfährt. Das gehört ja bei Ich reihe mich dritt in den letzten Jahren mittlerweile zu einer guten, erfolgreichen Saison dazu. Es ist nicht das erste Mal, dass Basse in den Dreiviertoren unterschied.
Du hast natürlich recht, aber…
Ja, also da hat man schon ein bisschen im Klassikogegen Basse hat man es an Effizienz und irgendwie auch Cleverness fehlen lassen, wenn es darum geht, irgendwie Basse das Abseitsfall ist zwölfmal zugeschnappt. Da hat man irgendwie nie ganz gecheckt. Und dann am Montag hat man natürlich auch ein bisschen was fehlen lassen. Also erstmal den Repräsentanten vielleicht nach Paris noch zu schicken oder trotzdem noch einen hinzuschicken. Auch irgendwie öffentliche Glückwünsche an denen. Auch für mich als Real Madrid-Fan, der nicht ganz unverdienten neuen Weltfußballer Rodri hat man da nicht hingeschickt. Also da lässt Real Madrid gerade einiges vermissen. Wie gesagt, ein bisschen klassisch vielleicht, dass man da irgendwie denkt, nein, das machen wir nicht. Wir sind gegen alle.
Über Platz 2, 3 und 4 kann man sich nicht freuen. Das passt ja dann doch wieder ganz gut zu Real. Aber weil du das...
Team des Jahres und Trainer des Jahres, ja.
Stimmt, das gab es ja auch noch. Wann gibt es das eigentlich bei den Frauen? Und wann wird eigentlich auch mal der ach so tolle Ballon d'Or angesetzt, wenn die Frauen auch anreisen können, weil sie nicht auf Länderspielreisen sind? Das sind Fragen, die müssen in Zukunft mal beantwortet werden.
Aitana war immerhin da, aber ja, hast du recht.
Jaja, klar. Natürlich, weil die alles getan haben, dass sie dann kommt und so weiter. Und ich meine, aber egal, das ist ein anderes Thema jetzt. Aber lass mal kurz beim Klassiker noch bleiben. Wir müssen jetzt nicht in die Spielanalyse rein gehen. Aber es war ja doch verwunderlich, dass Barca genau dasselbe gemacht hat, wegen gegen den FC Bayern und das genauso erfolgreich war. Also wie würdest du das denn bewerten, dass man es nicht geschafft hat, das Timing in den tiefen Pässen besser hinzubekommen? Weil daher kommen ja die vielen Abseits-Stellungen. Ist jetzt nicht so, dass Barca etwas ganz besonders machen würde bei seiner Abseits-Falle? Oder habe ich da was übersehen?
Besonders, was Barca macht, ist erstmal das Risiko, wo man sowohl in Hansi Flick loben kann, als auch wie die Innenverteidiger das dann immer wieder geschickt ausfällt und dann in den entsprechenden Momenten, in den letzten Momenten dann doch noch raus zurück und den Stürmer stehen zu lassen. Also Real Madrid hatte schon viele Angriffsphasen und Momente und ist auch mal durchgekommen, wo dann auch Mbappé seine zwei, drei Top-Chancen ausgelassen hat. Auch Vinicius da ein, zwei Mal noch vorm Tor eben dann nicht clever genug gewesen oder dann die Chancen nicht genutzt. Also an Chancen, an Situationen hat es nicht gemangelt, aber dass dann eben Real sich dann doch hier und da so ungeschickt angestellt hat, würde ich erstmal primär am Stürmer festmachen. Klar, mal kommt auch ein Abspiel vielleicht einen Ticken zu spät. Mbappé hat ja auch früh getroffen zum 1-0. Da kam vielleicht das Zuspiel von Lukas Vazquez, die Millisekunde zu spät, sodass dann die Kniescheibe von Mbappé im Absatz war. Ist okay, aber ich glaube, Kylian Mbappé von diesen zwölf Absatzsituationen war es achtmal eher, der dann irgendwie zu früh gestartet war. Und das ist schon irgendwo so eingeplant, dieses Kurz wieder reinziehen und dann starten. Aber er hat dann irgendwie gar keine Lernkurve gehabt und stand dann teilweise deutlich drin. Und man dachte sich schon, ich kann jetzt der Mittelfeldspieler gar nicht mehr anspielen. Und trotzdem kam der Pass und dann ging die Fahrt hoch. Also schon auch teils kläglich und ein bisschen peinlich von MWP meiner Meinung nach, da so gar nicht irgendwie die Lehren draus gezogen zu haben. Aber wie gesagt, trotzdem gefühlt hat Real sich besser darauf vorbereitet als die Bayern, kam öfter hinter die Kette. Und trotzdem verlierst du am Ende 0 zu 4. Also schon eine wahnsinnige Klassikogeschichte.
Jetzt sind 6 Punkte Rückstand auf Barca, denn man hat auch schon 3-mal unentschieden gespielt und Barca 10-mal bereits gewonnen. Also Barca 30 Punkte, Entschuldigung, Real Madrid 6 Punkte. Es war die 2. Niederlage dieser Saison. Sie kam aber auch unmittelbar nach einem Come-from-behind-Victory gegen Borussia Dortmund, den wir alle hier in Deutschland sehr gut mitbekommen haben, weil da sowohl die Euphorie in Teilen der ersten Hälfte als auch das Entsetzen in der zweiten Hälfte sehr, sehr groß und medial begleitet war. Wo steht denn jetzt Real Madrid deiner Meinung nach?
Ja, es ist immer noch eine Saison, wo es immer noch nach jedem Spieler heißt, ja uns fehlt immer noch Toni Kroos und Mbappé ist der Neue, der muss sich noch zurechtfinden und uns fehlt allerbar. Also Verletzungsprobleme auf der einen Seite. Natürlich war Toni Kroos die letzten zehn Jahre ein wichtiger Spieler, aber wir haben jetzt auch schon irgendwie 14, 15 Pflichtspiele und so richtig eine große Entwicklung nach vorne spürt man da auch noch nicht, dass dann irgendwie das Dortmund-Spiel gedreht wurde, lag ja auch nicht nur an Real Madrid, sondern vielleicht auch, was der Gegner dann noch in der Halbzeitpause da veranstaltet hat. Real Madrid sammelt durchaus Ergebnisse, auch wenn das nicht immer klappt. Man hat ja auch in Lille verloren und das auch nicht ganz zu in Recht. Also es gibt viele verschiedene Baustellen, dass vielleicht auch der Trainer nicht immer noch diesen berühmten Plan B dann in der Tasche hat. Aber ja, mal ist es auch ein bisschen einfach die Effektivität von einem Mbappé vorne. Und wie gesagt, der Klassiker hätte auch durchaus ganz anders ausgehen können, dass man vielleicht schon in der ersten Halbzeit in Führung liegt. Dann lag Barca irgendwann mit zwei Toren vorne. Auch da gab es dann wieder zwei, drei Top-Chancen, wo du nochmal hättest rankommen können gegen Dortmund. Hat das wunderbar geklappt. Dann war auch das Stadion natürlich wieder da eindrucksvoll. Aber Barca ist dann doch eher die Mannschaft, die nach einer Zweittore-Führung nicht verwaltet und verteidigt, sondern eher noch vorne drauf geht. Lewandowski hatte noch einen Pfosten-Treffer und so weiter. Also da die Klassikoniederlage geht so in Ordnung. Und das Real da mit einem ordentlichen Abstand mittlerweile hinter Barca ist, ist so gesehen auch in Ordnung. Denn für Barca ist es, glaube ich, mit diesen 30 Punkten, das hatten sie erst einmal überhaupt in ihrer Vereinsgeschichte, so eine Ausbeute in der Liga in den 50er-Jahren. Also es ist schon historisch, was Flick und wie Flick das da aktuell macht. Und da kann Real aktuell nur den Kützeren ziehen, weil dafür gibt es, wie gesagt, zu viele Probleme von Verletzten über Großfehlen und MVP noch nicht so richtig da, immer noch nicht so richtig. Ja, das so.
Aber da höre ich jetzt dann schon auch gewisse Zweifel bei dir raus oder überinterpretiere ich das. Also, weil du sagst, man hat ja schon so viele Pflichtspiele gehabt und langsam werden ja auch, also das kennen wir ja auch, es stimmt zwar, dass man Toni Groß abgegeben hat, es stimmt auch, dass man Verletzte hat, aber irgendwann kann man das nicht mehr hören. Irgendwann wirst du, dass sich das Team entwickelt.
Ja, es ist eigentlich eine sowohl junge Mannschaft, die auch schon einiges an abgezockt hat und Erfahrung hat und ekelig sein und schon ein paar Finals gewonnen hat. Also, sie sind jetzt nicht alle super naiv und sind eigentlich trotzdem alle noch hungrig genug, um auch mal wieder eine Meisterschaft zu verteidigen. Das gab es zuletzt 2008 bei Real. Ja, es gibt viele Probleme. Die beiden Innenverteidiger, Militär und Rüdiger sind sich ein bisschen zu ähnlich, sind beides eher so die Draufgänger. Da fehlt vielleicht wirklich so ein Kommunikator, wie Nachos gegangen, Alaba soll jetzt vielleicht im Dezember dann zurückkommen, endlich als Kommunikator. Es gibt da wie gesagt diese paar Baustellen und ich als Fan bin jetzt natürlich nicht zufrieden mit, kann auch hier und da Probleme verstehen. Aber es ist jetzt auch nicht so gewesen, dass in der letztjährigen Saison, wo Real Madrid ja sowohl Meisterschaft als auch Champions League gewonnen hat, dass da in der Hinrunde alles glorreich und galaktisch war, auch da wurde hier und da schon Carlo Ancelotti hinterfragt und hat sich gedacht, vielleicht wird ja jemand aus der Bundesliga im Sommer 2024 frei. Das ist in dem Fall nichts geworden, weil ja auch Ancelotti das Double gewonnen hat. Aber ja, es sind wieder berühmte alte Probleme zurück, dass hier und da viel auf Individuelles bei Real Madrid ausgelegt ist. Und das ist auch okay, mal durch einen Standard oder durch eine einzelne Aktion von Vini zu gewinnen, aber mannschaftstaktisch fehlt hier und da mal was.
Aber du sagst es ja, es sind alte und bekannte Probleme. Der große Jogi Hebel hat hier mal in der Ligatur gesagt, als wir über City gesprochen haben, die so ein bisschen– also sie haben unentschieden gespielt, zweimal nacheinander– da hat er damals gesagt, naja, die werden ja eh wieder ab März dann kein Spiel mehr verlieren. Warum hat Real Madrid keine größere Gelassenheit?
Auch die Gelassenheit ist im Club da. Ich rede jetzt natürlich mehr aus Fan-Perspektive und wie dann die Kommentare auf Social Media sind und an Céline Lotti raus. Aber natürlich wird da jetzt bei Real Madrid im Verein auch nicht ungedacht, dass jetzt im Winter vielleicht ein Transfer kommt. Also nicht mehr für die Rechtsverteidiger-Position, wo jetzt Cavajal für über ein Jahr ausfällt. Auch da wird man jetzt nicht nachlegen, weil man hat ja das Vertrauen in den Kader und will dann Lucas Vazquez dadurch das Vertrauen geben, indem er gesetzt ist und so. Das war auch das letzte Jahr das Geheimnis, als es ja auch drei Kreuzbandrisse gab, wo die Mannschaft dann so eine jetzt erst recht Mentalität entwickelt hat. Und es wäre auch nicht das erste Mal, dass Real in der Rückrunde dann auch physisch irgendwie an die 100 Prozent rankommt, wo es vielleicht hier und da auch noch irgendwie von der Belastung her Probleme gibt in dem Kalender. Also das ist schon alte Probleme, typische Probleme. Und da im Verein ist man da absolut gelassen, würde ich sagen, weil es sind trotzdem dann doch nur sechs Punkte und da ist noch alles möglich.
Und dementsprechend fasst nämlich vielleicht dieses ganze unwürdige Schauspiel rund um den Ballon d'Or perfekt zusammen, wie Real Madrid tickt. Das Problem von Real Madrid war, dass man bei dieser Wahl nur die Plätze 2, 3 und 4 belegt hat. Das heißt 99,9 Prozent aller anderen Vereine würden sagen, welches Problem? Ich habe ganz genau hingeguckt, ich erkenne da kein Problem. Wo sind die Shampoos-Flaschen? Und nur Real Madrid sagt, oh, das ist aber gemein. Jetzt kommen wir nicht. Und das ist halt einfach dieser Verein.
Ja, ich werde gleich noch was anderes sagen, aber Real Madrid hat natürlich irgendwo immer schon das Gefühl oder strahlt es aus, dass man irgendwie über den Dingen steht, dass man Dinge vielleicht besser weiß und auch versucht, irgendwie neue Prozesse anzustimmen, ob das auch in der Geschichte des Weltfußballs schon war, wo man dann auch mal den Europa-Pokal mit gegründet hat und so weiter. Jetzt mit der Super League. Anderes Thema. Die Plätze 2, 3, 4, auch noch 6 und 9 sind ja eigentlich schon ganz ordentlich, wenn man da 4, 5 Spieler in den Top 10 hat. Es ist nur jetzt dieses ganze Theater, was da am Montag so sich entwickelt hat, vom Wegen nach eigentlich war alles geplant und die Reise und der Anzug lagbereit. Dann doch die Absage kam jetzt nicht unbedingt durch das Wahlergebnis selbst. Wie gesagt, man kann da schon verstehen, dass ein Rotri die meisten Stimmen bekommen hat. Auch weil die Spieler auf den Plätzen 2, 3, 4, auch 6 und 9, die eigenen Spieler aus dem eigenen Stall, sich vielleicht gegenseitig die Stimmen ein bisschen wegkanibalisiert haben. Dass es eben nicht diesen einen Top-Kandidaten hatten, wie es Modric oder Benzema 2018, 2022 waren. Deswegen ist das Wahlergebnis demokratisch von diesen 100 Reportern durchaus nachzuvollziehen. Es geht dann nur ein bisschen um die Art, dass es vor Wochen irgendwie hieß. Jo, ihr kriegt ihn übrigens, bereitet alles vor und die Party könnt ihr planen. Und dass es dann auf einmal irgendwie Real Madrid selbst über Man City selbst herausgefunden hat, ach, wie ihr habt den Ballon d'Or. Ich dachte, wir. Uns wurde gesagt, dass so und so. Da, so diese Art und Weise, da ist man dann sehr sauer aufgestoßen, dann nicht mal irgendwie in Emilio Butadaguenjo als Repräsentanten hinzuschicken. Da sage ich dann schon auch, oh, das ist schon irgendwo peinlich. Und dass du jetzt nicht groß feiern musst, du bist Club des Jahres geworden, das ist egal, weil du hast ja erst mal einen Champions-League-Titel, darauf kommt es an, aber dann nicht mal dem Rotri öffentlich zu gratulieren. Das, was vielleicht im Hintergrund passiert ist. Rotri ist ja auch ein Spieler, der irgendwo auch auf dem Radar bei Real Madrid ist und könnte vielleicht irgendwann mal. Aber es ist jetzt nichts unbedingt, wo der Madridismo stolz sein drauf kann, auch wenn, wie gesagt, es sind dann andere Themen, der Clinch mit der UEFA und Super League und generell, dass der Real und UEFA nicht mehr die besten Freunde sind. Da kommt schon einiges zusammen, aber es geht jetzt nicht primär ums Wahlergebnis selbst.
Ja, okay. Das ist natürlich nochmal eine richtige Einordnung. Ich habe aber das Gefühl, auch über Real Madrid werden wir noch öfter sprechen in dieser Saison. Habe ich so im Gefühl. Da zwickt es mich in der linken Wade. Das ist immer ein Zeichen dafür. Aber dann lasst uns mal noch auf die Eredivisie blicken. Daniel, über wen wollen wir denn da sprechen? Was hast du uns mitgebracht?
Ich habe euch ein kleines Fußballmärchen mitgebracht, aus sportlicher Sicht, und zwar nicht PSV Eindhoven, die jetzt zum zehnten Mal in zehn Spielen gewinnen, mit 30 Punkten auf Platz 1 drohen und vermutlich wieder gewinnen werden, die Meisterschaften, sondern im Schatten quasi von Eindhoven. Auf Platz 3 ist FC Utrecht. Ein Verein, den man, glaube ich, außerhalb der Eredivisie nicht so wahrnimmt, und was auch– sei was so zu tun– etwas sportlich gesehen international länger nicht mehr vertreten war. Aber die sind auf Platz 3 mit 22 Punkten nach 9 Spielen. Und das ist vor allem bemerkenswert, wenn man sieht, woher dieser Verein kommt. Der war vor der letzten Saison, vor zehn Spieltagen, auf Platz 17. Und unter ihm war nur Ajax. Das war die Saison, wo Ajax auch nicht so gut war. Und da ist eine erstaunliche Entwicklung eingetreten, die jetzt quasi gegipfelt und kriminiert in der sportlichen Erfolgsfahrt, die sie aktuell führen. Und das hat vor allem mit dem jetzigen Trainer Baron Jans. Und in der vergangenen Saison war es so, dass sie nach drei Spieltagen die ersten drei Spiele alle verloren haben und haben dann schon ihren damaligen Trainer Silberbrauch ausgeworfen. Der hatte in der Vor-Saison auch immer mal so Höhen und Tiefen. Er saß jetzt nicht so fest im Sattel und nach dem sehr miterhabenden Saisonstart des letzten Saisons haben sie ihn rausgeschmissen. Dann kam Ron Janss und der hat im Prinzip zwei Kniffe mitgebracht, wie er dieses Team relativ schnell zu sportlichem Erfolg wiedergeführt hat. Das war einmal eine Umstellung vom System. Die haben mit einem 4-3-3 eigentlich gespielt, waren aber defensiv zu anfällig. Die Balance hat dann nicht ganz so gestimmt zwischen Offensive und Defensive. Und Janss hat umgestellt auf einen 4-2-3-1 mit Doppel-Sechs und hatte im Prinzip diese Idee von dieser kontrollierten Offensive. Das Wort hatte Mario auch schon heute benutzt, das alte reagliche Sprichwort, sag ich mal. Und damit ging es dann relativ gut. Also das ging auch zur Lasten der Offensive. Also Utrecht war unter Silberbauer ein Verein, der auch gerne mal ein Tor mehr getestet hat. Es gab dann auch so 4-3-3-3-Spiele, nämlich viel Harakiri. Das war vorbei und ist vorbei unter Janss. Und hat den Vorteil, dass sie auch mal Spiele dreckig gewinnen, mit ein, zwei Toren oder Differenz nur. Zum Vergleich, diese Saison haben sie jetzt das erste Mal verloren gegen Ferdinand im ersten Spieltag. Davor haben sie fast alles gewonnen und immer mit einem Tor. Es war 1-0, 2-1, 3-2, aber es war jetzt nie die dominante offensive Struktur, sondern immer mit Augenmerk auf die defensive Doppel-Six. Und das funktioniert. Der neue Stürmer haben sie geholt von Wahlweig, der aktuellen Saison Minden. Der holt sich die Bälle sehr tief ab, ist ein Misspielender, neuner, ist auch eine Art Wandspieler. Den sieht man eigentlich oft im Mittelkreis als Stürmer. Und das gefällt mir sehr gut, das funktioniert auch sehr gut. Und der andere Kniff, den Ron Jans mitgebracht hat, ist so ein bisschen das Teams-Bild. Also der ist sehr gut darin, das Team zusammenzuhalten, eine Mentalität reinzuschaffen, eine Positivität auch einzubauen. Gerade nach Niederlage und Hubschlägen sagt er quasi, ja, Kopf hoch, es geht weiter. Und ist ein großer Freund von Team-Bilding-Maßnahmen. Und das sagt auch Kapitän von Utrecht, Nick Vierhever, den kennt man vielleicht aus, Führth in der Abwehr. Der hat auch gesagt, ja, das ist extrem wichtig für uns, dass der wirklich diese Mannschaftsgeist bei uns bringt. Und das Erstaunliche ist, dass dann Utrecht vergangene Saison gegen Ajax gewonnen hat. Also gut, das ist nicht erstaunlich. Ich glaube, die nächste Saison hat sehr viele Teams gegen Ajax gewonnen. Aber das Erstaunliche ist dann, dass sie in der Hinrunde gegen Ajax gewonnen haben und dann bis zur Rückrunde gegen Ajax nicht sehr verloren haben letzte Saison. Die sind von 17 am Ende auf 7 hochgesprungen mit einem Kader, der bei allem Respekt durchschnittlich ist, bzw. eher ein bisschen unterdurchschnittlich war. Aber durch den passenden Trainer, den passenden Spielstil, diesen Fokus auf die Defensive und diese Mentalität, ein Wort, das man vielleicht nicht so gern hören will, aber meiner Ansicht nach ist es wichtig. Das funktioniert und es schafft dann möglich von 17 bis 7. Und jetzt, dass das Spannende, diese Leistung, diese Leistung wurde konserviert in die neue Saison hinein, trotz verschiedener Abgänge. Wir haben zum Beispiel Flamengo in der Abwehr. Der Innenverteidiger ist jetzt für ab 10 Millionen zu PSV gewechselt. Dann haben wir einen Sam Lammers, der jetzt bei Twente spielt. Wir haben einen Ligberg, der jetzt auch gestern für Darmstadt gegen Dresden getroffen hat und in der Liga auch schon, glaube ich, gut unterwegs ist bei Darmstadt. Der kam auch von Utrecht und trotzdem hat man es geschafft, diesen Erfolg und den Kern des Teams noch dazuhalten, mit vier Rehwerfer in der Abwehr, wo sie konservieren. Und jetzt ist man nach neu bespielten Spielen und zweiten Spieltag auf Rang 3 nicht unverdient und kann auf jeden Fall noch eine Überraschung werden in der Saison. Ich glaube auch, dass sie die Leistung halten können.
Ja. Lass mal noch einordnen, wer dieser Ron Jans ist, weil ich habe mir seine Vita jetzt angeguckt. Er ist einmal niederländischer Pokalsieger geworden. Das ist zehn Jahre her, mit Zwolle damals. Aber ansonsten sehe ich da, also Enskede hat trainiert in Groningen. Da war er sehr, sehr lange, gleich zu Beginn seiner Trainerkarriere. Er ist schon 66 Jahre alt. Also ist das auch für niederländische Expertinnen und Experten eine Überraschung, wie gut das funktioniert? Hat sich da was bei ihm verändert? Ist das jetzt sein zweiter Frühling?
Nein, Ronjans ist eigentlich ein bisschen immer so unterschätzt gewesen. Aber Ronjans hat auch bei Twente, da war ja vorher echt viel bewirkt. Die hatten ja– so zwente kennt man ja vielleicht noch aus den 10er Jahren, so 2010, 2011– aus der EuroLeague. Die hatten noch, glaube ich, auch wieder ein Gegend. Die hatten eine Saison, wo sie weit gekommen sind, und dann, glaube ich, an Bremen gescheitert.
Mario und ich auch.
Ja, ich auch. Jedenfalls bei Twente ist es so, dass sie dann in den letzten Jahren ein bisschen eingebüßt haben. Die hatten in diesen 10er Jahren den Status, wo sie ja auch schon regelmäßig in den Top 3 waren. Und dann wurden sie ein bisschen abgehängt, drifteten so langsam in das Tabell Mittelfeld hinein. Und Ronjans hat Twente dann so ein bisschen wieder zu Altrück Dagger geführt, war sehr erfolgreich und ist auch nicht rausgeschmissen worden, sondern es war seine Entscheidung damals vor zwei Jahren, seine Entscheidung aufzuhören, weil er das Gefühl hatte, dass er das Maximum erreicht hat im Prinzip und dass er nicht mehr viel bewirken kann. Und dass er auch, also hier und da bei der Stimmung gehört, dass er sich nicht ganz so wertgeschätzt gefühlt hat. Und das ist ihm eigentlich auch wichtig, das würde ich ihn als sehr bodenständigen Trainer und Mensch einfassen, der auch mit seiner Familie immer schöne kleine Häuser sucht und sich da auch einlebt, wenn die Stadt mit dem Menschen viel spricht. Und das Verhältnis zu den Fans auch sehr schätzt und ein sehr offener Mensch ist. Und deswegen überrascht mich nicht, dass er so erfolgreich ist, wenn er mit ihm trefft. Das kann man schon sagen. Das hätte ich dann nicht gedacht. Dass er aber grundsätzlich ein sehr guter Trainer ist, das ist...
Und es ist auch einfach schön, mal über jemand anderen zu sprechen. Weil wir hätten natürlich, als du gesagt hast, ein Fußballmännchen, da dachte ich mir, ah, jetzt kommt Ajax. Weil sie nicht mehr ganz so schlecht sind wie letzte Saison. Und mit ganz so schlecht ist es natürlich viel, viel besser. Aber da finde ich, also nichts gegen Ajax und alle Fans nicht beleidigt sein. Aber da finde ich so eine Utrecht-Geschichte viel interessanter. Weil davon habe ich gar nichts gehört. Ich habe jetzt alles nebenher nachgegoogelt.
Und eine Sache wollte ich dann noch in dem Sommer erzählen. Denn es ist auch ein sehr großer Bundesligatouch oder ehemaliger Bundesliga- und Zweitligatouch bei Utrecht. Wir haben zum Beispiel eine extrem wichtige Funktion von Oskar Fraulu. Das ist eine Leihgabe von der Bursche aus Klappbach. Übrigens auch Spandt, der ist jetzt Sechser. Kleide, die sind doch der Sechst. Und ich meine, mich zu erinnern, dass er bei Klappbach eigentlich eher so ein Achter, so offensiver war.
Einen Sechser könnten die gebrauchen, glaubst du mir. Ja. Täter übrigens auch, können die gemeinsam… So weit ist es ja nach Klappbach nicht, aber egal.
Und die nächste Leihgabe, Paxton Evans, macht ein überragendes Saison-Restaurant. Hat wirklich da auch dieses Auge für diesen tödlichen, wie es schon heißt, tödlichen Schildsternpass, der mal kommen kann. Es macht richtig Spaß, sie zuzusehen. Wir haben einen Bostrugendamm von Schalke zum Beispiel noch. Wir haben ja vier Rewe, der haben wir viertfach schon gesagt. Wir haben auch Taylor Booth, der war in der Jugend von Bayern. Und wir haben Mike van der Horn von Bielefeld. Das ist in diesem Bereich der Stamm, und hat zumindest sehr, sehr oft eingesetzt. Das heißt, da ist ein sehr großer und spannender Bundesliga-Touch auch drin.
Also auch aus diesem Grund kann man sich auf jeden Fall mal mit Utrecht befassen. Aktuell eben 3. geht es dann weiter gegen Lisse am 31. Das ist heute. Oh, heute. Ich bin nicht so ganz im Monat verhaftet, dass es jetzt schon wieder losgeht. Ganz hektisch die Gästehonorare überwiesen, vor allem Tag. Aber das ist ein anderes Thema. Wir wollen jetzt noch mal kurz durch die Ligen durchspringen und kürzere Geschichten erzählen, den Scheinwerfer drehen auf Spieler. Jogi, du darfst gerne mal wieder anfangen. Hast du jetzt am längsten nichts mehr sagen dürfen. Über welchen Spieler würdest du denn gerne als erstes reden?
Ja, es ist eigentlich auch jetzt nicht so besonderes, aber ich muss einfach sagen, Cole Palmer. Ich hatte am Wochenende Chelsea und es ist einfach beeindruckend, was dieser Spieler leistet. Also ich weiß nicht, ob ihr den Assist vor dem Assist gesehen habt, vor dem ersten Tor, wie Cole Palmer in der eigenen Hälfte den Ball quasi über 80 Meter genau zwischen Innenverteidiger und Außenverteidiger durchspielt. Ich habe mit Benni darüber gesprochen, dass er das zuletzt bei Messi gesehen hat. Dieses räumliche Denken, wie du aus dem eigenen Strafraum heraus erkennst, wenn ich ihn in diesen Korridor reinspiele. Ich habe es eh gesagt, wir haben ein Spiel, es ist nur dieser Korridor möglich, dass etwas passiert. Weil spielst du nach außen, hat ein Verteidiger vor sich, spielst du in die Mitte, hat einen der Innenverteidiger. Der spielt ihn genau durch und dann natürlich von Neto auch gut gemacht. Aber was der momentan da zeigt, das ist unglaublich, dieses Selbstvertrauen, dieses egal, was passiert. Ich gehe trotzdem weiter drauf, dann macht er später noch das Siegtor. Das ist schon sehr, sehr beeindruckend. Und habe ich so echt selten gesehen, dass jemand so den, teilweise wirkt es so, als würde der einfach seine kompletten Emotionen ausschalten und einfach nur wie eine Maschine durchlaufen und einfach nur das abrufen, was er kann. Das ist unglaublich. Und dass er Fußball spielen kann, ist sowieso klar. Das macht einfach richtig Spaß, dem zuzusehen. Das ist einfach, der hat diesen, einfach dieses ganz besondere in seinem Spiel.
Und man hat so das Gefühl, dass Chelsea jetzt so wirklich ins Rollen kommt. Also das, was man sich die ganze Zeit erhofft hat. Du hast ja vorhin Mariska schon mal angesprochen, den Trainer, also aktuell Rang 5. Aber ich glaube, es ist eher die Art und Weise, wie man gewisse Spiele jetzt gewonnen hat. Es gibt wieder mehr Gründe, Chelsea-Spiele zu gucken als in der letzten Saison.
Jetzt ist das jüngste Team der Liga, etwas über 23 Jahre. Das nächste jüngste ist bei 25 Jahren. Das heißt, da ist schon eine Diskrepanz zu sehen. Dass die Talent haben, ist klar. Ich glaube, wir alle wussten das. Aber Mareska hat jetzt herausgefunden, wen, wann, wo wir spielen lassen sollen, damit es funktioniert. Das war die erste Hälfte. Ich habe das eben mit Benni zusammen angeschaut. Der hat mir immer wieder bei WhatsApp geschrieben. Ich habe selten gesehen, dass eine Mannschaft eine andere so dekodiert hat. Du hast genau gewusst, die spielen diesmal zu viert hinten raus. Dann muss einer mehr schon drauf gehen. Dann ging einfach nur der Pass vorbei. Plötzlich war das ganze Mittelfeld offen. Die sind komplett draufgelaufen. So etwas habe ich selten gesehen in der Premier League. Dass einer durch so einen einfachen Kniff die komplette gegnerische Mannschaft– das war Newcastle United, darf man auch nicht vergessen. Top 8, wie der Engländer mittlerweile sagt. Die einfach auseinandergenommen hat. Das war wirklich sehr beeindruckend. Das ist dann angepasst worden, aber das war schon richtig gut. Auch so etwas, was man hört, ist ein sehr harter Hund, der in seinen Aussagen– er hat es Rhys James zum Beispiel öffentlich quasi kritisiert– gesagt, das ist kein Führungsspieler, von dem Führungsspieler erwarte ich mir mehr, du kriegst die Binde, also brauche ich mehr von dir und nicht weniger von dir. Das ist ja gerade in einer Phase, in der es eigentlich läuft, sehr untypisch, zeigt aber, wie der tickt. So ein bisschen Artäter ist in ihm drin, selbst wenn es läuft. Ich will trotzdem noch immer mehr, mehr, mehr. Und das ist wirklich das Beeindruckende und ich glaube, das kann wirklich funktionieren mit ihm.
Also wir werden es genau im Blick behalten, was sich da bei Chelsea tut. Jetzt wollen wir auch nochmal in die Serie A blicken. Mario, wer ist denn da ein Spieler, über den du jetzt hier noch sprechen wollen würdest?
Ja, damit wir Lazio auch nochmal wieder drin haben und den Arsenal-Bezug für Jogi persönlich, muss ich sagen, ist der bislang transfer des italienischen Sommers Nuno Tavares, der hat schon sieben Torvorlagen beigesteuert in sieben Spielen, also liegt gleich auf mit Bukayo Saka. Ich glaube, sonst in den Top 5 fliegen keine so viele Assists. Bukayo Saka, ein Spiel mehr, wenn wir den Vergleich ziehen angemerkt haben. Nee, aber das ist, ich glaube, wir hatten vor paar Wochen ja auch schon mal über Lazio gesprochen, wie sehr die überraschen, wie stark sie mit dem neuen Trainer Baroni sind. Ich weiß es natürlich nicht, lieber Max, wie viele Lazio-Spiele ich dir zumuten wollen würde, denn sie schlagen sehr viele Flanken und nur Tavares schlägt sehr viele Flanken. Aber sie machen halt auch Tore damit. Sie machen wirklich Tore und der geht da die, also er rennt die linke Seite hoch und runter wie ein Beklopter. Also, dass das ein guter Kicker war, glaube ich, hat man vor ein paar Jahren mal erahnen können. Und dann sich so gedacht, ja gut, dann vielleicht doch nicht so richtig, oder? Ich glaube, Nothing in Forest war er dann noch mal, wo er auch nicht so richtig gezündet hat. Und jetzt hat er wohl in Rom so seinen Ort gefunden, an dem er funktioniert, zumindest jetzt im ersten Saisonviertel. Macht Spaß, Lazio anzugucken und dem besonders, weil er da mit Leib und Seele Fußball spielt, so glaube ich, kann man sagen.
Und wird er dann nach dem oder im Sommer wieder zu Arsenal zurückkehren oder weiß man da schon was, ob es da Kaufoptionen und so gibt?
Die haben auf jeden Fall eine Kaufoption. Ich kann mir auch nicht vorstellen, dass Arsenal ansonsten, das Kader, was sie sonst zu haben, den unbedingt wieder zurück haben wollen. Also ich glaube, Lazio kann auf jeden Fall sich an ihm bedienen.
Okay, ich habe Zustimmung bei Jogi gesehen.
Es gab auch einen Streit zwischen Ateta und Tavares. Das war in England ziemlich groß. Das war ziemlich öffentlich. Die haben sich, glaube ich, in der Vorbereitung gekeift. Ich glaube nicht, dass das noch mal zum Punkt kommt. Es ist nicht auszuschließen, weil Ateta und Saliba haben sich ja auch wieder gefunden. Da gab es ja auch Probleme zwischen den beiden. Deswegen ist es nicht auszuschließen. Ateta ist dann auch jemand, der schon auch dann Sportsmann ist und sagt, okay, dann ist es vorbei. Aber ja.
Okay, also nur Notavarez, schaut ihn euch an. Und gut geschlagen und gut vorbereitete Flanken, da habe ich ja gar nichts gegen. Es geht ja nur um diese dummen Bundesliga-Flanken, die man manchmal sieht. Auch nicht bei allen Teams.
Ich habe mir gestern 90 Minuten Bozventon Terror von Mielefeld angucken müssen.
Ja, wobei die aber wenigstens noch nachrückende Achter und der Außenverteidiger da reinläuft. Das heißt, viele der Flanken sind okay, aber gestern ging Mielefeld– ich habe es nur so mit einem Auge in der Konferenz gesehen– da hat halt Mielefeld gewusst, was kommt und konnte die 1 zu 0-Führung der eigenen melken. Ja, das war schlimm. Aber gut, wir jetzt hier nicht zu viel Bundesliga mit reinbringen. Haben wir schon genug mit drin gehabt. Lasst uns lieber nochmal nach Spanien blicken. Nils, wen hast du uns denn da mitgebracht, über den du jetzt noch ein paar Worte verlieren wollen würdest?
Ich bringe auch einen Club, die es auch eher flach halten. Und nachdem eigentlich hätte man auch vielleicht, wenn Jogi schon gesagt hatte, die jüngste Mannschaft der Liga, das wäre hier in La Liga natürlich der FC Barcelona. Aber ich glaube, ihr hattet in den letzten Ligatouren über Lewandowski, über Rafinha, der ist über einen Lamine Jamal öfter mal erwähnt. Also, die wären schon MVP-Material immer noch. Aber ich nehme jetzt den Trainer von Las Palmas. Die waren lange, lange Tabellenletzter, mehr oder weniger hoffnungslos insgesamt. 23 Spieltages, saisonübergreifend ohne Sieg. Ja, und dann kam auf einmal Diego Martinez. Und jetzt hat er aus zwei Spielen zwei Siege geholt. Also, das ist schon mal spektakulär, dass es da erst einen 3-2-Sieg in Valencia gab. Und jetzt haben sie auch noch zu Hause gegen Girona gewonnen. Okay, Doppelbelastung bei denen. Aber das ist schon mal eine starke Quote, was der da holt. Der war ja schon früher erfolgreich in Granada aufgestiegen, dann sogar nach Europa eingezogen. Espanol, Olympiakus, war nicht ganz so erfolgreich. Aber jetzt eben Diego Martinez holt da wieder einiges raus bei Las Palmas. Und auch sehr erwähnenswert, dass er da auch gleich nach dem ersten Sieg gesagt hat von Mignot. Schöne Arbeit, aber danke auch noch mal an den vorherigen Trainern. Luis Carreon, bei dem man sich da bedankt hatte. Also da merkt man mal wieder, das ist einfach manchmal eine Pechsträhne. Und du kommst da nicht raus, egal was du für gute Arbeit leistest als vorheriger Trainer. Aber dann hat es eben diesen neuen Impuls gebraucht. Und da jetzt mit sechs Punkten, ein kleiner Sprung vom Letzten auf den drittletzten Tabellenplatz. Immerhin, also Las Palmas da wieder zurück.
Ja, naja, aber wieder zurück, sagt sich so leicht. Aber genau so ist es ja. Also die waren abgeschlagen und jetzt mitten in der Verlosung mit drin. Kann man denn sagen, hat er irgendwelche Dinge gemacht, die man bei ihm schon bei vorherigen Stationen gesehen hat? Also er war ja schon viel in La Liga unterwegs. Jetzt zuletzt dann bei Pireus. Da habe ich ehrlich gesagt gar nichts mitbekommen. Keine Ahnung, wie viel du da auf dem Zettel hast. Aber gibt es ein Signature-Martines-Ding, was er dann macht bei neuen Teams und das funktioniert gut?
Ich glaube, mit Granada war es einfach so ein bisschen auch dieser Underdog-Fußball und dann eben schnell das Umschaltspiel. Jetzt bei Las Palmas ist er gefühlt noch ein bisschen bei alten Dingen gewesen. Deswegen war Las Palmas schon die letzte Hinrunde ziemlich stark. Das spricht sowohl gutes Ballbesitzfußball mit hohen Passwerten usw. Es ist gar nicht so hoch mit Flanken, sondern sie versuchen es schon flach. Und das hat irgendwie in der Rückrunde, dass man da eingebrochen. Das hat nicht mehr geklappt. Deswegen ist er jetzt auch– Diego Martínez ist schon der dritte Trainer innerhalb von fünf Monaten. Pimienta ist ja zum FC Sevilla gewechselt im Sommer. Und da ist er einfach gefühlt, hat er die Mannschaft wieder auf seiner alten Stärken besinnt, wegen Sachen ein bisschen sowohl hinsichtlich Passquoten Ballbesitz. Ist man jetzt überall in den vorderen Dritteln, wenn nicht sogar viertelnder Liga dabei. Und jetzt klappt es einfach wieder, dass dann vorne auch wieder ein bisschen die Effektivität zurück ist. Das hätte gegen Girona sogar noch ein bisschen höher ausfallen können. Der Sieger Basanto Ramírez hat da noch eine vergeben. Also es ist jetzt noch nicht unbedingt die ganz klare Tegermartines-Sprache. Vielleicht aufgrund der kurzen Zeit hat er eher noch mal bei dem angesetzt, was Las Palmas schon stark gemacht hat. Und das klappt bisher. Und jetzt mal gucken, wie es dann weitergeht.
Ja, und das bringt, glaube ich, einige da unten zu schwitzen. Das gibt einen klaren Cut bei Retafel. Die liegen auf Rang 15, haben auch nur zehn Punkte. Aber danach kommen Teams, die aus den letzten sechs Spielen sehr, sehr viele verloren haben. Alaves, fünf aus sechs verloren. Espanyol, fünf aus sechs verloren. Jetzt Las Palmas, eben nur drei aus sechs verloren. Valladolid, vier aus sechs verloren. Und dann Valencia, über die werden wir, glaube ich, noch mal gleich kurz sprechen. Deswegen, da muss man... Ja, also da hilft es, wenn du eins der Teams bist, das als einziges einen positiven Trend da unten drin hat. Wir werden das weiter verfolgen. Dann ist jetzt die Frage, lieber Daniel, auf wen wir den Blick werfen wollen in der Ehre, oder in der Division?
Ich habe ein zweites Fußballmärchen mitgebracht. Denn nach Utrecht gibt es auch Breda. Breda ist Aufsteiger und die sind aktuell auf Platz sieben. Das ist eine echt gute Saison mit 15 Punkten. Da sticht eigentlich ein Mann sehr stark raus, nämlich Clint Lehmans. Das ist ein Mittelfeldspieler, eher defensiv, aber eigentlich oft offensiv eingesetzt bei Breda. Er hat in der ersten Beile Saison-Tore erzielt gegen Walweig am Wochenende. Eins wird ein wunderschöner Freistoß, Traumfreistoß. Das ist eigentlich der Unterschiedspieler für Breda. Man merkt vor allem an der sehr schönen Statistik, dass die ersten Spieler letztlich gefehlt sind. Aus den Spielen hat Breda 1 gewonnen und 3 verloren, oder 4 verloren sogar. Mit ihm haben sie 4 gewonnen und nur 1 verloren. Auch die Statistik zeigt, wie wichtig er ist. Breda als Aufsteiger ist sehr mutig in die Saison gestartet, mit sehr viel Pressing-Fußball, dominanten Fußball, aggressiven Fußball. Und Lehmann ist im Prinzip dann so das Pressing-Monster im Mittelfeld. Bei Breda geht früh drauf, sehr laufstark, ballsicher und macht einfach auch Spaß, Breda zuzusehen. Und der Mut wird dann auch belohnt, was immer sehr schön ist, finde ich.
Und weil wir jetzt schon zum zweiten Mal über ein Team sprechen, das keinen großen Namen hat, in Anführungszeichen, also alle kennen den Namen, jeder, der mal irgendeine Fußballsimulation gespielt hat, oder inwiefern, Nackt-Breda, das ist einfach, ich weiß nicht warum, aber das habe ich als Kind schon fasziniert. Aber haben denn solche Teams, Utrecht, Nackt-Breda, wenn die so besondere Trainer, Spieler und so weiter haben, haben die denn auch die Chance, irgendwas zu gewinnen in den Niederlanden? Oder ist es dann doch eher so eine schöne Geschichte und am Ende der Saison haben wir sie aber dann doch vergessen?
Leider letzteres eher. Das Problem ist, dass die top 3, 4 Vereine da oben, insbesondere Eindhoven, im Momentanen so stark sind, dass sie, auch wenn sie jetzt auf sieben sind, jetzt ist es schon eine Geschichte, die werden, denke ich, mal nicht absteigen. Dazu gibt es andere Vereine wie Zwolle zum Beispiel, die momentan fast gar nichts auf die Reihe kriegen, leider. Aber die werden nicht irgendwie in den Interesse der Hettbewerb kommen. Dazu sind die Vereine oben zu stark. Und da gibt es auch eine relativ große Kluft, auch finanziell gesehen, zwischen so Teams wie Wahlwaik, Preda und anderen und halt den wirklichen Clubs. Alax findet, haben wir eben schon leicht angespielt, wieder jetzt in die Spur. Haben auch den Klassiker gewonnen gegen Feyenoord gestern. Das will ich auch mal noch mal als Ajax-Feld auch noch mal erwähnen am Rande. Und das führt auch dazu, dass das im Prinzip funde Geschichten sind. Und man muss sich dann, wenn man es mit Preda oder Utrecht hält, freuen, wenn sie dann auf Platz 6-7, 5-6-7 dann wirklich landen am Ende der Saison. Dann ist das schon ein großer Erfolg. Man hat ja auch noch Aset Alkmaar und Twente, die auch beide international spielen. Und das wird einfach sehr schwierig für so einen kleineren Verein. Dann dort auch. Fuhst du fast dauerhaft. Was halt immer noch möglich ist, ist natürlich Epokalp-Werb im Titel zu holen. Aber auch da hat man am Ende ja auch dann wieder irgendwann irgendwelchen Runden dann failen, oder Ajax-Fails-Wale. Und da braucht es dann schon nochmal ein größeres Wunder. Das ist leider so. Aber ich will es nicht ausschließen. Ich würde es mir auch mal wünschen. Das wäre ja eine tolle Story. Aber wenn es den Spieler schafft, dann wird es Klink-Lehmanns. Und dann mal den MVP hervorzuheben.
Genau. Und genau deswegen haben wir ja diese Kategorie, damit solche Teams eben auch mal zumindest kurz vorkommen. Dann lasst uns nochmal in die Premier League blicken. Yogi, wen hast du denn da noch, auf den es sich lohnt, einen Blick zu werfen?
Also der Anzang Hero, glaube ich, hast du gemeint. Das wäre bei mir tatsächlich Bernd Leno. Den hatten wir gestern im Interview. Er ist jetzt vielleicht einer, der trotzdem halt den jeder kennt, logischerweise. Aber der wirklich wieder herausragend ist diese Saison. Wir haben gestern mit ihm sprechen können. Und vor allem auch solche Sachen wie diese Expected Goals-Werte, wie viel er da momentan rausholt. Auch die letzten Jahre schon über. Ich habe dann im Vorfeld noch mit René Adler sprechen können, der mir auch nochmal erklärt hat, warum Bernd Leno so gut ist. Also, er meinte zu mir, er ist einer der besten Torverteidiger der Welt. Also wirklich, wenn es nur darum geht, Bälle zu halten. Und Fulham ist momentan Zehnta. Die könnten noch weit drüber stehen. Die haben richtig gute Spiele gemacht. Und der ist für mich, und dann können wir ja den größeren Bogen spannen, total unterrepräsentiert in Deutschland. Ich glaube, das ist immer einfach zu sagen. Nur, er spielt da bei Fulham beim Zehnta einen, ja, da hat jetzt, glaube ich, keiner große Emotionen, außer man denkt vielleicht an Stadion oder sonst irgendetwas in die Richtung. Dass man sagt, das ist so ein Kultstadion, okay. Nur, ich glaube, es kriegt gar keiner mit, wie gut der ist. Und dass das wirklich einer der besten Keeper Europas ist, kriegt gar keiner mit. Und das tut mir so ein bisschen leid, weil es ist, Bernd Leno ist momentan weit mehr, wenn du den googlst, gibt es nur die Nationalmannschaftstebatte und sonst nichts. Und die Leistungen kriegt gar keiner mit. Und wenn es nur darum geht, wie er hält, was er hält, dann wäre der wahrscheinlich momentan sogar die Nummer 1 in Deutschland. Und das ist halt das, was ich so ein bisschen schade finde. Und ja, genau, deswegen glaube ich, muss man das auch mal erwähnen und ihn da vielleicht so ein bisschen rausnehmen, als nur diese Nationalmannschaftsdebatte.
Ja, das ist jetzt so ärgerlich, weil das ist die erste Frage, die ich aber auch dazu habe. Also ihr werdet ja bestimmt mit ihm auch darüber gesprochen haben. Hat er sich dann mit nicht selbst auch ein Problem geschaffen, dass er überhaupt diese Debatte hat aufkommen lassen, indem er eben nicht anreist?
Ja, also er hat uns gegen ihn auch erklärt, dass das ganz sehr klar besprochen war. Er hat eine Frage bekommen, so quasi, willst du es machen? Er hat dann keine Forderungen gestellt, sondern hat gesagt, so quasi, na ja, okay, wenn ich nicht spiele, also er hat ihm gesagt worden, du hast gar keine Chance zu spielen, so quasi. Also wörtlich hat er es nicht gesagt, aber so ungefähr. Und dann kann ich das total nachvollziehen. Und da sind wir ihm dann ehrlich gesagt in die Bresche gesprungen, weil der Mann ist jetzt mittlerweile 32, er spielt in England, er hat diesen Rhythmus ja trotzdem mit allen drei, quasi alle drei Tagen Spiel, weil in England das ja einfach mittlerweile so ist, mit den Cup-Wettbewerben und so weiter und so fort. Er ist über 30, er hat das alles schon mitgemacht, er muss niemandem mehr was beweisen. Und ich persönlich muss auch sagen, wir können ja zum Beispiel mal Mario fragen. Mario, wenn ich dir jetzt sage, du reist mit mir jetzt bitte mit, weil ich kommentiere Chelsea gegen Liverpool, und du reist mit und du bist einfach nur da, falls ich ausfalle, dann wirst du auch sagen, sorry, aber das habe ich nicht mehr nötig, ich habe jetzt Familie, ich habe mittlerweile auch schon ein paar Sachen gemacht, sorry. Also nur, dass ich mich jetzt hinter dich auf die Bank setze, falls du das Mikrofon nicht auf deinen großen Kopf bekommst, das kann ich schon nachvollziehen, dass er da sagt, sorry, das tue ich mir nicht mehr an. Ich glaube, eine gewisse Perspektive brauchst du dann schon als Torhüter auch. Ich kann es total nachvollziehen. Ich habe mit einem ehemaligen Nationalspieler gesprochen, der zu mir gesagt hat, das Ding ist halt einfach nur, du hast halt immer dieses Problem, dass DFB halt immer dieses Thema ist, das halt nicht nur eine Mannschaft ist, zu der du reist, sondern es ist ja immer dann auch dieses Ding national Mannschaft, und etwas ganz Besonderes und eine Ehre und so weiter und so fort. Und das ist halt dann etwas, was noch draufkommt. Und dann ist es einfach keine rationale Diskussion mehr.
Was ist dein Lieblingssingen, Yogi? Theoretisch? Das ist das einzige, was mir nicht zählt, ob sie die Hymne singen.
Genau, aber ich weiß, er hat uns gesagt, dann trainiert er halt lieber in London, weil er da halt weiß, es bringt mir was, und das andere bringt mir halt einfach nur Strapazen. Das kann ich halt nachvollziehen. Und da war gestern, ich kann total nachvollziehen, weil wir ja alle wissen, ich versetze mich halt immer in die Position desjenigen rein und denke mir halt einfach, okay, wo ist der gerade in seiner Karriere? Wo ist der gerade als Mensch? Der hat Familie, der ist über 30, der musste aus London anreisen, der hat genug Strapazen, das bringt ihm alles nicht, dann lass ma's doch gleich bleiben. Wenn die jetzt gesagt hätten, du kriegst eine Chance, also du kriegst eins der beiden Spiele, vielleicht, wir schauen uns das mal an, dann wäre er gekommen, hat er zu uns gesagt. Und das kann ich halt schon nachvollziehen, dass man dann eben sagt, du einfach nur auf die Bank sitzen, das muss jetzt auch nicht sein.
Alles Weitere dann in eurer Folge Click&Rush, die wird natürlich in die Show Notes gepackt mit dem Kapitän vom FC Fulham, Bernd Leno. Nicht schlecht, mein Lieber. So Mario, über wen wollen wir in der Serie A noch sprechen?
Ja, zum ersten muss ich natürlich sagen, wenn Yogi London kommt drauf an, wie viele Tage dann und wer das Abendessen zahlt, aber sonst würde ich das natürlich…
Das würde ich bezahlen. Mario, du trinkst mittlerweile nichts mehr, das wird billig, das passt.
Stimmt. Aus Italien würde ich gerne einmal, weil wir haben in der Vorbesprechung ja auch kurz gesagt, hatten wir noch gar nicht und deswegen ist so ein bisschen mein bislang zu wenig besungener Held Raffaele Palladino, der Trainer der Fiorentina, ein bisschen stockend reingekommen in diese Saison. Gab ja ein Trainer-Karussell, der war letztes Jahr in Monza, er hat jetzt für Italiano bei der Fiorentina übernommen, der ja zu Bologna ist, weil Motta zu Juve ist, wer das alles nicht mitbekommen hat. Und dann ging es bei der Fiorentina los mit einer sehr durchwachsenen Europa Conference League Qualifikation gegen einen ungarischen Vertreter, wo man dann auch ins Elfmeterschießen musste. De Gea hat da gehalten, dann hat man in der Liga nur einen Punkt gegen die beiden Aufsteiger plus auch Monza, die es ganz unten drin stehen, geholt, nochmal gegen Atalanta verloren. Und jetzt sind die, wenn die heute nach der Aufzeichnung wird noch gekickt, gewinnen, sind die dritter. Und die letzten Spiele waren 6-0 bei Lecce, dann 4-2 in St. Gallen, dann haben sie die Roma 5-1 weggefiedelt. Mois Ken trifft auch einmal das Tor wieder. Und das liegt eben auch an einem, wie ich finde, sehr smarten Trainer, der sich auch nicht zu schade war, sein System ein bisschen anzupassen. Zu Beginn der Saison noch mit einer 3er-Kette gestartet. Das war so ein 3-4-2-1. Jetzt spielt er meistens wieder mit einer 4er-Kette hinten, wo er dann auch links uns Robin Gosens, der hoch und runter rennt, der, glaube ich, da auch wieder einfach in Italien sein Fußballland gefunden hat, wie ich sagen soll. Das ist Wahnsinn. Die Fiorentina ist auf jeden Fall eines der Teams, bei denen das Trainerkarussell stand jetzt, positive Spuren hinterlassen hat. Wir erinnern uns vielleicht auch noch bei der Viola, die zwei Conference League-Final ist, in denen sie eingezogen sind, wo sie dann kaum Torgefahr entwickelt haben. Das war irgendwie unter Italiano, der auch ein guter Trainer ist, keine Frage. Aber immer so ein bisschen das Problem. Und jetzt kommt Palladino und schmeißt die Offensivmaschine an. Ja, auch Gegentore finden tatsächlich auch statt. Aber aus neutraler Sicht kann man sich das durchaus angucken, was Florenz da so zeigt.
Aber wirklich, haben vielleicht auch der ein oder andere und die ein oder andere mitbekommen, dieses 5 zu 1 gegen die Roma. Da darf man zumindest mal spielen. Und dann verursacht er ein Eigentor und kriegt mit 1 zu 5 auf die Mütze. Aber so geht es eben. Und wir wollen bei den Trainern bleiben, Nils. Du hast uns auch einen Trainer mitgebracht, und zwar einen großen Namen.
Einen großen Namen, das ist der von Manuel Pellegrini. Also der wurde schon durchaus oft besungen, auch in der Fußballwelt. Er hat ja schon einige Stationen hinter sich. Er wurde nur nicht unbedingt immer besungen nach Spielen gegen die Top 3. Also er hat eine sehr schlechte Bilanz eigentlich gegen Greer Madrid, gegen Barcelona, gegen Atletico und das auch mit Bettis. Da hat er aus insgesamt um die 40 Duellen erst einen Sieg geholt. Die Serie konnte er jetzt ein bisschen aufhübschen am Wochenende, da hat er nämlich Diego Simeone im 13. Anlauf zum überhaupt ersten Mal geschlagen. Und da steht so ein bisschen die Geschichte über diesem Spieltag. Der älteste Trainer der Liga, Pellegrini, mit 71 Jahren, hat den dienstältesten Trainer Simeone geschlagen. Und ja, zeigt ein bisschen, dass da jetzt Bettis irgendwie, der Held jetzt seit einigen Jahren weiter oben hat, der auch 2022 Pokal gewonnen. Jetzt sind sie wieder irgendwie auf Platz 6, gleich mit dem fünften aus Bilbao. Direktes Duell am Wochenende. Also das ist schon stark, was Pellegrini da Jahr für Jahr macht. Mit auch einem Club, der auch ziemlich viele finanzielle Probleme hat.
Aber wirklich über 200 Spiele jetzt schon für Bettis. Und wir haben Bettis immer mal wieder positiv erwähnt. Und dann viel sein Name auch. Aber das ist wirklich nochmal, wenn man sich diese Trainerstation anguckt. Ich meine Real Manchester City dazwischen. Aber auch immer wieder verschwunden, sage ich jetzt mal bei West Ham war er dann jetzt zuletzt. Es ist einfach ein faszinierender Trainer, der ja auch über 70 Jahre, 71 Jahre inzwischen schon alt ist. Unglaublich. Frisur gleichgeblieben. Alter. Aber nach oben gegangen. Sehr, sehr schön. Manuel Pellegrini. Haben wir den hier auch noch untergebracht? Und wen bringen wir aus der RE. Divisi noch unter, Daniel?
Wir bringen einen Bekannten aus von Werder unter Debbie Claßen. Der ist jetzt bei Ajax gesetzt. Und das ist auch schon das Besondere im Prinzip, schon teilweise, denn Fahri Yoli ist ein Meister der Rotation. Der fängt jetzt die Medien und auch auf Twitter. In Social Media gibt es hervorragende Memes, die sagen, der dreht völlig durch. Der wechselt teilweise fünf, sechs Mal in der Startelf durch, hat eigentlich nicht so einen wirklichen Kern. Und trotzdem bringt es langsam den Erfolg. Da hat sich jetzt auch, glaube ich, Zorrel Harto, der 18-jährige Linksverteidiger von Ajax, auch geäußert, dass die Mannschaft sich damit arrangiert hat und abgefunden hat mit diesen Wechseln. Aber es funktioniert und hat vor allem den Vorteil, dass es für die Gegner sehr unberechenbar ist, wer denn eigentlich dann mit welcher Elf Ajax spielt. Aber Debbie Claßen ist davon beides genannt ausgenommen. Gegen Karabach international in der EL war er jetzt nicht in der Startelf, aber in der Liga, glaube ich, jetzt vier, fünf Mal in Folge, hat auch schon vier Tore in sieben Eintrassen gesammelt als Mittelfeldspieler und übernimmt sofort Verantwortung und ist auch für diese relativ junge Truppe, die Ajax mittlerweile aus verschiedenen Sekunden jetzt zusammen hat, auch, glaube ich, als eine Art Mentor und Leader einfach sauvichtig geworden. Und jetzt bei dem Klassiker gestern gegen Feyenoord hat auch eben Jena Harto im Interview nochmal betont, wie wichtig auch ein Henderson ist und wie wichtig auch vor allem ein Klaassen ist für nicht nur diesen Sieg, sondern generell auch für diesen Aufschwung, den Ajax jetzt erlebt. Und Klaassen ist ja auch so, das Gesicht im Prinzip von Ajax war ja schon zweimal dort, ist da groß geworden, steht eigentlich für die ganzen, auch die guten, erfolgreichen Zeiten, die Ajax erlebt hat. Und ist trotzdem so ein bisschen ein Ansagengeber, weil der Fokus dann doch eher auf den Talenten liegt, wie eben Harto oder auf Rückkehrer, wie Neuankömmlinge wie Wechors zum Beispiel oder wie Kachotz, der junge Belgier vorne in der Offensive, der auch sehr viel jetzt im Fokus steht. Und so ein, ja sag mal, alter Hauding wie Klaassen ist dann nicht mehr so, kriegt nicht mehr so die Blumen, die er aktuell verdient, weil er momentan echt nochmal aufpült im Prinzip und für Ajax extrem wichtig ist aus verschiedensten Gründen mit den Toren, die Stabilität, die er reinbringt und das Leadership, was er hat. Und deswegen will ich ja unbedingt noch an der wie Klaassen hervorheben. Und wer es schafft, unter Fahrioli so eine Art Stammspieler zu sein, der hat es geschafft. Also insofern der wie Klaassen. Alle Augen auf ihn.
Sehr, sehr schön. Ja, Francesco Fahrioli. Ich glaube, über den werden wir noch häufiger sprechen in den nächsten Jahren. Kam ja von Nizza und das, was da aktuell mit Ajax passiert, das sieht sehr, sehr gut aus. Einmal springen wir noch durch die Ligen hindurch. Wir beginnen wieder bei der Premier League. Jogi, was ist so eine Geschichte der Woche, die man noch wissen muss?
Ja, das Spiel Arsenal gegen Liverpool. Ich glaube, das war nochmal sehr, sehr interessant, weil es ja doch ein sehr verrücktes Spiel war und da ja auch dann wieder eine Menge Ärger gab um die Geschichte– ich weiß nicht, ob ihr es mitbekommen habt– mit Kai Havertz, als der ja quasi den Ball annimmt, durch ist, mehr oder minder, und dann aber der Pfiff erfolgte und keiner eigentlich so wirklich wusste, warum es gepfiffen worden ist und dann aber ja auch nicht wirklich aufgelöst worden ist, dann aber in der Folge rauskam, dass er wahrscheinlich selbst wenn der Pfiff nicht gekommen wäre, also viel Konjunktiv, trotzdem wahrscheinlich dann den Pfiff gehört hätte, im Nachhinein durch den VAR, weil er mit dem Ball da oben mit der Hand gespielt hat, so am Oberarm und das dann dementsprechend genommen worden wäre und gab Ich hab ne Menge Diskussionen dann auch bei Schiedsrichterentscheidungen, zum Beispiel Van Dijk, der hat dreimal ausgetreten gegen Kai Havertz, zieht dafür nur gelb. Dann gibt's noch ne Geschichte von Martinelli, wird im Strafraum von Conaté umgehauen, gibt keinen Straffluss. Also Arsenal hadert gerade so mit den Schiedsrichtern. Es ist nicht so, dass sie irgendwie verpfiffen werden oder so, das gibt's ja sowieso nicht, aber es ist schon so, dass sie Entscheidungen momentan nicht für sich bekommen. Das muss man schon sagen, das war ja schon öfter zu sehen, dass dann im Endeffekt einfach auch bei den roten Karten, wenn es sind drei in der Zahl jetzt schon wieder in dieser Saison, da hätte man bei der einen oder anderen vielleicht auch ein Auge zudrücken können, aber sie kriegen die einfach. Und das ist einfach momentan etwas, die werden schon erwischt. Was vielleicht auch daher kommt, dass Mikkel Arthäter da draußen auch immer rumtollt, es gab letzte Saison, wissen wir aus einer sehr, sehr guten Quelle, dass Schiedsrichter angehalten worden sind, in der Premier League Hertha durchzugreifen, weil sie gesagt haben, sowas wie Mikkel Arthäter da draußen macht, geht nicht und das dürfen wir nicht einreißen lassen. Das zeigt ja schon, wo der herkommt, zeigt, wie der da draußen ist. Und ich glaube, dass Arsenal da momentan bei den Schiedsrichtern jetzt nicht gerade die größten Sympathiepunkte hat, was nicht heißt, dass ich jetzt sage, dass da irgendwas gegen sie läuft, nur sie kriegen halt wenig Bonus. Sagen wir es mal so.
Also am Ende war es dann eben ein 2 zu 2, ein Unentschieden, da mit Liverpool vier Punkte vor Arsenal. Und auch deswegen natürlich da sehr viel Ärger drum. Kurze Frage mit– bitte um kurze Antwort. Wenn ich mir bei dem Spiel angucke, 9 zu 9 Schüsse, war das jetzt dann trotzdem hochintensiv und hoch dramatisch oder haben die sich gegenseitig plattgecoacht?
Da war schon was drin. Also ich fand vor allem halt sehr, sehr giftig. Das hast du von Anfang an gemerkt, dass beide eine Vorgeschichte miteinander haben und das Beides sehr, sehr ernst genommen haben. Und auch da sind ja wirklich Streithähne drin ohne Ende. Also Kai Havertz, ich sage das auch immer wieder, wenn der in Deutschland immer als soft oder sowas verschrieben worden ist, schaut euch den mal an. Schaut euch den mal an, wie der ist teilweise drüber. Dass der einfach dann einen Verteidiger mal anschubst oder irgendwie drauf tritt oder auch mal eine Geste macht oder so. Der ist schon, das ist momentan genau das Gegenteil. Das ist eher so ein Aggressivling und Van Dijk dann auch noch und so. Also das war schon nicht ohne die beiden Trainer dann auch noch gegeneinander. Also das ist schon, da war eine Menge drin in dieser Partie und ich glaube, ich bin selten so oft angeschrieben worden dann, was sagst du zu dieser Szene, das muss doch sein, das ist doch das und das. Also das war auch, hast du gemerkt, dass auch die Zuschauer richtig angezündet waren. Ich weiß nie, woher das kommt, aber es war wirklich sehr, sehr schön zu sehen, was ein Spiel dann machen kann mit deiner Timeline.
Ja, und was ein Spieler manchmal auch mit einer Timeline machen kann, das haben wir bei der Geschichte, die Mario mitgebracht hat, bekommen. Wir haben viele Anknüpfungspunkte. Ich hätte jetzt jede Stiche rauspacken können von Joki und damit eine Überleitung bauen können zu Mario Balotelli.
Ja, ich weiß auch gar nicht, wie sehr sich da die Schiedsrichter in der Serie A drauf freuen. Ich kann nur sagen, bislang ist es ja noch gar keine Geschichte. Die ganzen Geschichten kommen noch, aber ich freue mich mausmäßig drauf. Also ich weiß nicht, ob das großartig Sinn macht für den CFC Genua, aber es ist ein großes Spektakel.
Aber wie kam es denn jetzt dazu, dass er zu Genua gewechselt ist?
Na, er hat ja keinen Verein mehr seit Juni gehabt. Er war davor noch bei Adana Demispor. Wie gut er sich selber fit gehalten hat, wage ich nicht zu beurteilen. Genua war letztes Jahr so ein bisschen ja als Aufsteiger das Team der Stunde. Dann hatten sie aber gerade offensiv großen Adalast. Sie haben Albert Gutmundson abgegeben an die Chorentiner. Matteo Retegui haben wir, glaube ich, habt ihr vor zwei Wochen ja auch darüber gesprochen, der bei Atalanta alles zerschießt, geht denen auch ab. Sie haben sich Pina Monti, wie ich finde, auch einen Stürmer mit Zukunft geholt. Trotzdem sind sie jetzt Letzter und tun sich sehr schwer. Alberto Ciladino meint, dass es ein Upgrade ist, auf jeden Fall noch Mario Balotelli jetzt in der Mannschaft zu haben. Also ich finde das eh. Alberto Ciladino coacht Mario Balotelli. Er kann jetzt da ankommen und dem wirklich sofort weiterhelfen.
Könnte aber auch Max Kruse bei Paterborn werden.
Genau, ich weiß nicht. Der ist jetzt 34. Ich meine, dass der über eine große Qualität verfügt. Das ist unbestritten. Der kann die einen aus 40 Metern ins Netz schweißen und haut das Tornetz raus. Der hat auch noch seine Tore klar in der Türkei gemacht und bei Sion davor, Nitsa. Er ist halt ein streitbarer Charakter. Ich glaube, das da gibt es nicht. Das ist entweder so oder so. Entweder ganz weit, entweder großes Chaos oder es funktioniert, aber so, dass das jetzt einfach ruhig läuft und der da sagt, ja, gut, wenn du willst, dann komme ich die letzten zehn Minuten rein und versuche mal. Ich sehe es nicht kommen. Und auf der anderen Seite frage ich mich natürlich auch als Stürmer, da ist in dem Kader, dass du dir dann irgendwie Ende Oktober denkst, okay, und jetzt holt ihr den Balotelli oder was ist eigentlich euer Problem? Also, das birgt ganz viel Zündstoff und ich freue mich. Und so ist, glaube ich, auch das große Medienecho, dass sich sehr viele freuen, dass der verlorene Gang der Sohn wieder zurück in der Serie A ist, so ein bisschen, weil ich meine, der hat ja trotzdem schon auch einen Stellenwert und da auch jetzt das Standing ist nicht nur komplett Chaos-Kit. Wir erinnern uns, der hat auch für die Nationalmannschaft das ein oder andere gute Spiel gemacht. Also, ja. Aber ich glaube sozusagen, die wirklichen Geschichten, die kommen erst noch mit Ihnen jetzt.
Stark, das heißt, es ist quasi eine Geschichte in der Zukunft. Und dann springen wir von einem Tabellenletzten, nämlich in der Serie A, zum anderen Tabellenletzten. Ich habe es vorhin schon kurz angedeutet. Nils in La Liga, nämlich Valencia. Was zur Hölle ist denn schon wieder mit Valencia los?
Da gibt es mal wieder an sich genügend Stories, jetzt auch mal abgesehen von der Flutkatastrophe um Dana, was mehr auch um Valencia drum herum ist. Aber ja, Valencia mal wieder Tabellenletzter. Und dort ist jetzt, das ist erstmal natürlich eine krasse Geschichte, dass dort die Negativspirale weitergeht, nachdem sie sich in der V-Saison noch eher gehalten haben. Aber irgendwie ist da wieder absolute Krise angesagt mit einer sehr jungen Truppe, die auch natürlich gut ausgesaugt wurde. Darüber will ich eigentlich primär reden vom Investor Peter Lehm, der die letzten Jahre natürlich aufgefallen ist, eher die Spieler zu verkaufen als irgendwie zu investieren in den Vereinen oder geschweige denn in die Infrastruktur. Deswegen hat ja auch der FC Valencia oder die Stadt Valencia die WM 2030 noch nicht bekommen oder da ist noch kein Standort und versucht jetzt doch noch irgendwie am 9. Nesteia das irgendwie hinzubekommen. Aber die Geschichte ist da eher von Peter Lehm. Das war jetzt während der Länderspielpause, also schon wieder zwei Wochen her. Da gab es nämlich ein Ehepaar aus Valencia. Die haben ihre Flitterwochen in Singapur gemacht und dort lebt Peter Lehm und da haben die sich gedacht, so auch ja komm, wir fahren mal vor das Haus von Peter Lehm. Ich habe hier mein Lehm-Go-Home-Plakat dabei. Das sieht man überall in Spanien, auch bei der EM habe ich es oft gesehen. Also die Proteste gegen Peter Lehm, ohne dass das jetzt eine krasse Beleidigung ist. Damit hat der Typ sich dann vor dem Haus von Peter Lehm ein Foto ablichten lassen. Dann hat er wohl auch noch ein Sticker Lehm-Go-Home auf die Gartentür von diesem Haus gepappt. Und auf einmal heißt es, die beiden sind festgenommen, irgendwie in ihrem Hotelpässe abgenommen. Und das jetzt nicht von Behörden, offiziell Polizei, sondern dann irgendwie Sicherheitsdienst. Nach ein paar Tagen sind sie wieder auf freien Fuß gekommen, wenn man das so bezeichnen will. Und ja, war so eine kleine Machtdemonstration von einem Investor, der gezeigt hat, hey, mit mir solltet ihr euch nicht weiter anlegen. Also, ja, ein bisschen unschöne Szene. Wie gesagt, das Ehepaar ist längst wieder in Valencia. Aber da hat Peter Lim mal ein bisschen Muskeln spielen lassen, was ich jetzt gar nicht so cool meine, wie das vielleicht klingt.
Oh, der Typ, ey, der wäre ein eigenes Tribünengespräch wert. Aber ja, eine Episode von vielen von Peter Lim. Und ich hatte bei meiner Launing-Überleitung total vergessen, was in Valencia passiert ist. Also das sollte nicht so launig rübergehen, denn das sind ja ganz anzuresorgend, die man da gerade dort in der Region und ja nicht nur dort hat. Also sorry dafür. Da war ich kurz im sportlichen Gefangenen. Da gehen wir jetzt aber auch hin bzw. wir bleiben da, nämlich wenn wir nochmal auf die Ehre-Divise blicken. Welches Märchen hast du jetzt diesmal für uns dabei? Es begab sich zu einer Zeit, das Daniel vorgetragen hat.
Wenn wir in dem Sprachbild bleiben, ist es ein Märchen des Krauns. Jetzt ist ein neuer Rekord der Ehre-Divise aufgestellt worden mit fünf Eigentoren an einem Spieltag, jetzt am vergangenen Spieltag. Und das Märchen des Krauns geht weiter. Zwei davon diesen Spielen sind auch 1-0 geendet. Das heißt, wir hatten dann wirklich zwei, vermutlich sehr traurige Profi-Spieler, die das verantworten haben. Und das waren teilweise Eigentore, wo man sagen kann, gut, da kannst du nichts für, das ist blöd abgefälscht. Oder wenn du nicht hingehst, da kommt der einlaufende Stürmer, der anders. Du hast aber auch zwei Dinge dabei, die auch für dich herausragend in ihrer Negativität sind. Du hast einen Rückpass auf den Torwart, der Torwart steht halt nicht mehr im Tor. Sondern man wollte sich anspielbar, wollte sich eine Anspielstation anbieten, irgendwie links oder rechts vom Tor. Und der hat ein Hadega, guckt nicht wirklich hin, sieht ihn, er wird angelaufen, passt zurück zum Torwart, da gut, er ist halt nicht mehr im Tor. Und das andere eigentlich, was auch herausragend ist in der Schönheit der Zerstörung, wenn man das mal so formulieren möchte, ist eine Klärungsaktion von Bakuna von Groningen, in der auch leider schon 84. kurz vorm Ende, die hat noch 0-0. Wenn er im Getümmel will, er den Ball klären, möchte ihn seitlich wegschaufeln, trifft ihn aber voll spannend in der Mitte und knallt ihn unter die Latte des Eigentorwagens. Die kann man sich auch noch anschauen auf Instagram und Twitter bei ESPN NL, müsste noch ein bisschen abrufbar sein. Kann man sich mal anschauen, ist sehr, sehr unterhaltsam, auch wenn es ein bisschen traurig ist. Ich habe mir dann mal überlegt, wo ist der Report in der Bundesliga? Der steht auch bei fünf Gegentoren. Und der ist aus der Saison 15, 16, 13. Spiele 15, 16, unter anderem. Und so können wir den Kreis, glaube ich, schön schließen. Mats Hummels hat da einen Eigentor natürlich produziert für Dortmund und der Nutzer, dieser war der HSV, lang ist es her. Und die haben 3-1 gewonnen, HSV gegen Dortmund, unter anderem Mats Hummels. Also, das ist der Kreis. Die Eredivisie zieht gleich mit den meisten Eigentoren an einem Tag mit der Bundesliga.
Und damit sind wir am Ende da gelandet, wo wir alle hingehören, in Deutschland, in der Bundesliga. Aber Mats Hummels, wie er hier erwähnt wurde, das wird ihm nicht gefallen. Aber gut, kommt für ein Tribüngespräch vorbei, dann können wir auch über andere Themen sprechen. Ihr vier, ich danke euch sehr, sehr herzlich, dass ihr euch die Zeit genommen habt an diesem Donnerstagvormittag. Mario, Rika, Nilskern, Jogi Hebel, Daniel Zander, herzlichen Dank, dass ihr mit dabei wart. Danke euch. Wir müssen irgendwie das mit der Verabschiedung, ich krieg's nicht besser hin, da muss ich mir mal noch mal was überlegen. Was ich aber auf jeden Fall hinkriege, ist, euch zu sagen, dass der Rasenfunk weiter werbe, paywall und sponsorenfrei bleibt. Wir finanzieren uns ausschließlich über eure freiwillige Unterstützung auf rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Erfahrt ihr, wie man uns unterstützen kann. Und in dieser Folge möchte ich mich bedanken bei Sam Chris, bei Frank Rossdeuter, bei Merckx, beim Würzburger, beim Grasnarben-Sammler und bei Björn. rasenfunk.de/supportersclubdaerfahrtihr, wie man uns unterstützen kann. Und ihr könnt uns auch unterstützen, indem ihr diesen Rasenfunk hier bewertet, diesen Podcast hier bewertet und uns weiter empfehlt. In diesem Sinne bleibt gesund, bleibt uns gewogen und bis bald hier im Rasenfunk. Macht es gut. Ciao.
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen. Vielen Dank.